[Music]
this is our last show of the week so I
thought we'd check in now with our own
Andy Richter see what stories he's
working on for next week thanks Conan
next week we'll visit the controversial
new show penises and Tiaras and one
perfectly nice man's crippling disease
that makes him look like a douche bag
plus highlights from the final round of
the black men who can't play basketball
tournament and the inspiring story of a
man and his seeing-eye giraffe and are
you a murderer who hasn't been caught
I'd love to interview you for my new
show Andy Richter catches America's
dumbest murderers and finally is
drinking beer on the job bad for you no
it's not
[Applause]
bad sorry what I said I think it is bad
for you if you drink a lot of beer on
the job I think it's bad it's not bad at
all coated it's good for you I think if
you keep doing it even when the sketch
is over it's a sign that you've got a
problem Andy why don't you shut up mind
your own business
maybe I got a reason to drink alright
[Applause]
we'll take a break when we come back
[Applause]